li journée ont compris que lorsqu'on est
l équilibre budgétaire on est vraiment
sur plus de trop bien je pense que tout
le monde y compris le surplus après
contributions sont une nation qui le
ferait sur plus le surplus compte en bas
mais on a bien compris en effet l'avenir
du fonds des générations fait partie des
enjeux prébudgétaires également du
ministre girard à québec
une fois qu'on aura atteint toutes les
cibles de réduction de dette
qu'allons-nous faire du fonds des
générations avec nous ici à maurice de
la chaire en fiscalité et en finances
publiques de l'université de sherbrooke
il c'est maurice bonsoir sangsues
clients j'ai passé cet extrait là qu'ils
étaient lors de la présentation du bilan
de la fiscalité parce que dans le fond
le ministre dit clairement qu'on dégage
beaucoup de surplus pour alimenter le
fonds des générations et la question est
de savoir puisqu'on atteint nos objectif
qu'est ce qu'on va faire du fonds des
générations
effectivement la question est légitime
parce qu'on va voir atteindre les
objectifs fois-ci poser la question
qu'est ce qu'on fait le fond ce qu'on
regarde ce qu'on le lit mine tout
simplement et on va se poser des
questions aussi qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec les sommes qui sont déposés
présentement dans le fond des jaunards
de générations entre le tome 3 milliards
dont le ministre parle en fait c'est la
somme qui est déposé dans le fonds des
générations
un pôle automatiquement à produire
annuellement proxima jones après 3
milliards donc qu'est ce qu'on va faire
avec ces sommes leur ce qu'on va
diminuer impôts augmenter les dépenses
ce qu'on va créer un ou deux font pas
autre chose
donc c'est un peu la table combien on
voyait venir la question voyait venir
cette question l'excentrique semblait
donc à charolles tenter de réfléchir de
mai des options sur la table je mets le
feu
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce frère de
générations futures et donc à partir des
données du ministère des finances
et on va regarder ça dans le tableau
qu'on a qu'on a préparé vous avez fait
des projections dans le temps oui sur
l'évaluation du fonds des générations
donc avec les versements qu'on va faire
puis avec les revirements
les revenus de placement tout à fait
important donc on voit que radmila temps
on a quand même des versions mac sont
autour de 2,7 milliards incluant les
revenus classement et on est à 12
milliards 1,26 nom qu'il a
date de la loi de la réduction et sur le
fonds des générations
la date des objectifs fixés pour les
cibles de dettes dont 45% pour la dette
brute et 17% pour la dette représentant
les déficits cumulés donc le 31 mars
2000 26 on avait 30 milliards dans le
fond et là on atteindre les deux
objectifs seront atteints
donc celui de la dette brute horaire 45
pour ça qu'on attendait chaque année
d'ailleurs
on va devoir dans l'instant mais juste
dire que si on continue comme ça on s'en
va à cent milliards exactement fonds en
2036 dans 15 ans tout à fait un
versement 10 milliards exactement
incluant les revenus de placements non
certain que ça va être difficile pour le
gouvernement d'avoir un fonds de 100
milliards qui est disponible comme ça et
ça restera donc c'est ce qui va des
décisions pourraient être prises
il va avoir des remboursements qui
seront faits au cours de ces années là
donc on note simplement projeter pour
justement alimenter notre réflexion sur
l'avenir du fonds des générations
c'est très intéressant de projeter
théoriquement parce que ça nous fait
comprendre que le 3 milliards dont parle
le ministre aujourd'hui dire ça m'a dit
milliards dans 15 ans alors jusqu'où on
va aller oui dans un sens exact alors
allons au graphique que vous avez
préparé qui nous montre bien le ratio de
la dette au pib donc c'est la valeur de
la dette par rapport à l'ensemble de
l'économie
l'objectif c'est que ça va être un objet
que c'était ça l'objectif des deux
objectifs y en a deux sont pour la date
de l'exercice 25-26 donc au 31 mars 2000
26 donc actuellement on est à 44,1
l'objectif est de 45% pour la dette
brute en 25 26 mai actuellement est à 44
donc on est déjà atteint cet objectif là
le deuxième objectif c'est sur la dette
sur des déficits cumulés notre la somme
des déficits dans le temps elle doit pas
dépasser 2 7% à 25 26
on aura 16 2% si on utilise la
définition de la diète déficits cumulés
qui existe dans la loi
sauf que le ministre même pas beaucoup
cette définition a alors il change il
voudrait changer la définition il
devrait exclure la réserve de
stabilisation de cette des plats sucrés
brécé la dette des déficits cumulés
donc on obtiendrait on atteindrait la
cible d'un an au cours de l'exercice 23
24 et on comprend que le gouvernement
dans son prochain budget devra faire des
pressions budgétaires dont 11 06 24 25
parce que la livre à nous donner des
indications sur ce qui va faire avec
respect parce que la loi prévoit que ces
2026 la loi prévoit que le 31 mars 2000
26 mais là on atteint nos objectifs pour
la d'être breton latin déjà joué cette
année et la dette des déficits cumulés
on voit la taille plutôt prévu aussi oui
selon la définition de la loi ce serait
à 25 26 mai selon la nouvelle définition
que voudrait donner le ministre soit
23.4 donc il faut il faut une nouvelle
loi où il faut définir de nouveaux
objectifs
il ya plusieurs options et c'est un peu
ce qu'on voulait amener sur la terre
parce qu'ils vont discussions a fait sur
les options dont condé absent c'est bon
à 30 ans à 25,28 d'abord parce que le
ministre veut éliminer la loi parce
qu'on a atteint les deux objectifs à
23,24 c'est une question on pourrait
voir on prend quand même le continuer
jusqu'à 25 26 parce qu'on ne sait pas
que c'est pour être passée en d2 et
revient d'une dernière année là par une
forte récession j'étais donc on pourrait
quand même conservé la loi jusqu'en 25
26 après qu'est ce qu'on fait première
option
on détruit on détruit le fond on rend
pas l'argent qui est dans le fonds des
générations
huambo cela dit la question qu'on se
pose c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les
sommes qui sont déposées dans le fonds
des générations
est-ce qu'on baisse les impôts parce
qu'on augmente les dépenses ou est ce
qu'on le conserve comme étant un surplus
qu'on mettra la dette par la suite sans
avoir une obligation dans une loi comme
utile donc ça c'est une option
deuxième option serait de créer de
nouveaux objectifs l'aviron point dit
que 10 à 35
36 on pourrait avoir un objectif par
exemple des bruits de 38% presque donné
d'autre objectif on peut changer
l'objectif aussi au niveau de la diète
bétons prêts à utiliser la dette nette
on sait que la dette nette du québec est
quand même parmi les plus élevés les
provinces canadiennes non seulement
internet qui dépensent donc on est à 40
% l'ensemble des provinces et 29%
donc on pourrait se donner comme
objectif de rejoindre la moyenne des
autres provinces canadiennes nouveau de
le détenir
on pourrait aussi décider de d'éliminer
complètement la dette des déficits
cumulés sur les grès fiction peut voir
que on atteint presque zéro en deux mais
35 36
donc si on continue le fond on pourrait
éliminer complètement la dette calculée
par les déficits cumulés ce que le
gouvernement appelle la mauvaise dit non
de la dot est payé par les cartes de
crédit au début de la réponse viendra
dans le budget on espère d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que dans les consultations
prébudgétaires 2010 pose la question
qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec les sommes
qui sont déposées au fond génération à
partir de 23h à suivre en mars prochain
x et maurice merci fait plaisir c'est
beaucoup